first consider the expression for
negative five plus the quantity of four
times x now take the product of negative
eight and that expression and then add
six so let's do it step by step first
we're gonna have this expression
negative five plus something so it's
going to be negative 5
plus the quantity of 4 times x
the quantity of 4 times x well that's
just going to be 4x so it's going to be
negative 5 plus 4x so that's this
expression up here now take the product
of negative 8 so let's take negative 8
and we're going to multiply the product
of negative 8 and that expression so
we're going to take negative 8 and
multiply it so that expression is this
thing that expression
is this thing right over here so the
product if we say the product of
negative 8 in that expression is going
to be negative 8 times
times that expression that expression is
negative five plus four x
so that's negative eight that's that
expression the product
the product of the two
the product of the two so we could put a
multiplication sign there or we could
just leave that out in implicit it would
mean multiplication take the product of
negative eight and that expression and
then add six
so that's and then add six so that would
be then adding six right over here so we
could write it as negative eight open
parenthesis negative five plus four x
and then add six let's do one more
first consider the expression
the sum of seven the sum of seven and so
that's going to be 7 plus something and
the product of negative 2 and x
the product of negative 2 and x is
negative 2x negative 2x so 7 plus
negative 2x we could write that as 7
minus 2x so this is equal to 7 minus 2x
this these are the same expression
what expression would be 4 plus
so now we're saying 4 plus
4 plus the quantity of 2 times that
expression so it's going to be 4 plus
some quantity
4 plus the quantity i'll put that in
parentheses the quantity of 2 times
do this in magenta of 2 times that
expression or in yellow 2 times that
expression
that let me do this in blue
that expression is this thing right over
here so the 4 plus the quantity of two
times that expression two times
seven minus two x
and we are done